Hi, everyone.
My name is Rachel
Gordon, and I'm
the communications and
media relations coordinator
at MIT's Computer Science
and Artificial Intelligence
Laboratory.
Today I'm joined by AI and data
scientist, Cameron Hamilton,
who recently found love on
the hugely popular Netflix
show "Love is Blind."
He's the founder of the
startup AI Alliance,
which focuses on tailor
made AI solutions
across all industries.
Thanks for joining us today.
Thank you so much for
having me, Rachel.
Pleasure to be here.
You're known mostly for
your work in AI and science,
but you recently
ventured into the world
of reality television?
Do you see any connection
between these two worlds?
You know, that's
a good question.
I think that "Love is Blind"
is a special kind of show,
and it's even more than a show.
It's an experiment in
some sense, you know.
It's an experiment
where the creators
were interested in seeing,
well, if we remove--
as I kind of said on the show--
these confounding variables
of physical appearance,
ethnicity, race, background, et
cetera, can people
just make a connection
based purely on the
conversation that they've had?
And I think I was drawn
to the experimental setup,
if you will.
I was intrigued by it.
I thought, you know,
I just want to see
where this goes and
see if there's merit
to doing dating in this way.
Interesting.
Let's go back to the beginning.
Were you always inclined
towards the sciences?
Absolutely.
I always had a sense of wanting
to know how things worked.
And even more than that, knowing
how the physical laws can
be used to create new things.
And I think that's what
ultimately led me to AI,
you know.
How can we build solutions with
what we know about the world
and how things work?
So I've also had
this creative side,
and I think that's where
the two intersect is,
you know, wanting
to create something
not just to understand, but
to create from what we know.
Interesting.
So I understand from your
bio that you were also
once a firefighter.
How did you make the segue
from firefighting into AI?
Well, so firefighting
for me was a seasonal job
where a lot of wildfires in the
summertime and the late spring.
So I did that during college
and grad school as a way
to kind of save up
money for college,
and also to just have some
adventures outside of academia,
and to do, you know, good.
To do something that would be
a positive thing on society.
So that was kind of
my side of adventure,
and I think that
adventurous side of me
also is what led me to do
"Love is Blind" as well.
And what question or
challenge were you
setting out to address when
you started your company?
Did you feel as though something
was lacking in the field?
Absolutely.
One thing I've seen
in the field of AI
is when companies
start to get bigger,
they have a hard time moving
course or changing direction,
you know.
They're kind of like
a train on a track
where they've picked
up a lot of momentum
and they have a hard
time diverting course.
I wanted to start a company that
was mobile and able to really
tackle nuanced problems
that these bigger AI
companies aren't able to do.
And even more
specifically, there
are certain problems
that I wanted to address,
and that's why I
started my own company.
I wanted to be able to
work on these problems.
So my biggest interest is
in Parkinson's disease.
I think there's a
lot of room there
for implementing AI to
be able to do earlier
diagnosis on the disease,
potentially improve some
of the treatments that
treat Parkinson's disease
such as deep brain stimulation.
I think there's room there to
optimize how DBS devices are
used to treat Parkinson's.
So those are some
of my motivations
for starting Alliance AI.
That's great.
I want to talk a little bit
about digital dating now.
Given that algorithms
are powering
much of our dating apps and
the focus there is largely
on physical appearance, did
your interest in the show
stem from a personal
belief that perhaps looks
are overemphasized?
Yeah.
So I was having that
experience myself
where I was using the
apps and, admittedly, I
was doing it in kind
of a shallow way, which
the apps kind of set you up
to do where you're seeing
the pictures of the person,
or all the people on the app,
and you're just
clicking yes or no.
I like them.
I don't like them, without
really thinking about them
as a person, and
there's thousands
of people on these apps.
So you're just kind of
going through yes and no.
And what I was
finding was, I was
finding people who I thought
were physically attractive,
but when I went
out on the dates,
there was no real
connection there,
whether a shared interest
or an emotional connection.
So I was just kind
of running into a lot
of dating dead ends as it were.
So all the more reason I wanted
to try this experiment out
and see if, you know,
removing physical appearance
could be a positive boon.
But do you feel that this
structure possibly short
changes some of the natural
and biological aspects
of attraction that
really only exist
in a physical space like
pheromone transmission?
Well, I think it would
be unwise to deny
that physical
attraction is certainly
a very, very important
part of a relationship.
We need it, frankly.
We need to be
physically attracted.
Physical intimacy is a
necessity in a relationship.
I think that we also need that
emotional connection as well.
So you know, doing
this experiment,
it was a case where
I was able to--
well, let me put it like this.
We were able to build
the emotional connection.
For some, obviously, when
they got to see each other
physically that physical
connection wasn't there.
So it was a bit of a risk
to do it in this fashion,
but it did allow us all
to focus on building
that emotional connection at
first kind of as a foundation.
But I think both are needed.
That emotional connection,
the physical connection,
being aligned on
values, you know.
How are you going to
raise children together?
Are your spiritual beliefs
at least compatible
enough so that you're not
butting heads constantly,
especially if you're
going to raise children.
And how are you going to
manage a household together?
So there's so many different
things to consider when you're
finding that lifetime partner.
Did you entertain the
possibility of disappointment
if you weren't physically
attracted to your fiancee
when you first met her?
Oh yeah.
Of course.
I mean there's-- in my
mind, there was a very real
possibility that we wouldn't
be attracted to each other.
Either she wasn't going
to be attracted to me,
or I was going to
be attracted to her.
But I thought that,
you know, since we
have such a strong bond before
we've even seen each other,
if there's less physical
attraction there than I would
want, I thought there
might be a possibility it
could build over time.
And I think that happens.
I think that if you
love someone for reasons
other than their
physical appearance,
you can build even such
that you become more
physically attracted to them.
I definitely agree with that.
How do you see AI shaping
the future of dating?
We've kind of come a long
way since the first iteration
of OkCupid.
Right.
And there's so many
apps that are tailor
made to different preferences.
But with all your
experiences, how do you
see the future of that?
That's a great question.
So yeah, I started thinking
about the current state
of dating apps.
And what I've seen
and what I can assume
is that they're using some
variation of collaborative
filtering to underlie
the algorithms there.
Where, you know,
they're rating people
and it's kind of a cold
start problem at first where
the app doesn't know
the type of people
that this person
is interested in.
And then the apps
start to narrow down
based on the history
of who they've said
they liked and didn't like.
But I think there's kind
of an inherent problem
there where after using the
app for a period of time,
it starts to narrow the
scope of potential candidates
so much that you're not
exploring these people
outside of that recommended
group of people who actually
may be a great complement
to you or a great match.
So that's something
that I think could
be improved upon in the future.
And also, perhaps an app
that was able to look at a
means for incorporating
the emotional component
the relationship and finding
someone who is a match there,
or these other factors that
we mentioned such as managing
a household together,
shared beliefs on family,
and finances, and
these type of things.
So a more comprehensive app
that was not simply looking
at physical appearance, which I
still think is very important,
but also emotional connection
and shared belief systems
in these other domains as well.
So there's just so much to
consider with a partner.
I think that that's the future
of dating apps is something
that's more comprehensive.
And after this experience
on "Love is Blind," would
you recommend this
format to other people.
Oh yeah, absolutely.
I would certainly recommend
the "Love is Blind" approach.
With that being
said, I think it's
all about you as an individual
and how you go into it.
Just like dating in
any other format,
there's a certain level of
openness and vulnerability
that you'd need to be willing
to expose yourself to.
So that's the main
takeaway I had was,
if you want to make
this work, you kind of
have to go into a prepared.
You have to go into it
being willing to take
the chance that
you may get hurt,
and you have to be brave
enough to expose yourself
emotionally and be
willing to give it a shot.
Right.
Now, pulling back a
little more generally,
where do you see the
future of AI going?
5, 10 years from now, whether
that's your personal goals
or just more largely?
Wow.
So the future of
AI as I see it, I
think it's going to
diverge from this vision
that we see in science
fiction where there's
some maleficent AI that
has a mind of its own
and is taking over things.
I think the real positive
trajectory for AI
is to think about
how AI in human life
can kind of integrate
in such a way
that the AI is only augmenting
what we naturally do.
It's giving us a better quality
of life on a day to day.
You know, whether that's
improving the way that we
schedule our day, whether
that's cutting down
the amount of time we spend
doing sort of minute tasks.
Basically, I see
the future of AI
is giving us more
time to be creative
by automating tasks,
allowing us to dig deeper
by helping us to do
research, and helping us
to be more creative in general.
And hopefully to be
able to spend more time
with other people and connect.
That's a really good point.
Well, thank you so
much for joining us.
Do you have any parting words
or advice for our viewers?
Wow.
Parting advice, I
would say, you know,
if you're worried about
dating, to first kind of figure
out what you want in a
partner and really to dig deep
and think, you know, what is
it about my potential partner
that I'm going to really
need in the long term?
And to be willing to be
vulnerable enough to let them
know who you really are even
if they might reject that.
So that would be my advice.
And on AI front for
the general public,
I would say to not
be afraid of the AI.
The future of it
I don't think will
resemble what we see in
sci-fi like the Skynet
and this type of thing.
We need to start
thinking about AI
in terms of how we can use it
to augment our day to day life.
That's great.
Thank you so much.
Yes.
Thank you for having me.